problem 20 the expression 5 to the minus
8 times 7 to the minus 9 is equal to
which of the following and here we see a
bunch of answers let's see where they
have a 35 there so I suspect that they
want to some have a somehow multiply the
5 times the 7 so let me write this in
terms that I have an easier time
understanding it so 5 to the minus 8
times 7 to the minus 9 that's the same
thing as 1 over 5 to the 8 times 1 over
7 to the 9 the negative in the exponent
just means 1 over the base to the
positive exponent that's all the
negative means that's equal to 1 over 5
to the 8 times 7 to the 9 and that's not
one of our answers somehow we have to
multiply the 5 and the 7 and the way we
can do that is by having the same
exponent so let me rewrite let me
rewrite 7 to the 9 I can rewrite that as
7 to the 8th power times 7 so then our
whole expression becomes 1 over 5 to the
8 times 7 to the 8 times 7
all right I just rewrote this I rewrote
7 to the 9 to 7 to the 8 times 7 but now
if I group this just put parentheses
around it I can do that because
multiplication is associative I doesn't
matter what order I do it this is the
same thing as 5 times 7 to the eighth
power
right a to the x times B to the X is the
same thing as a B to the X the same
thing as 5 times 7 to the eighth power
so this is equal to 1 over 5 times 7 to
the 8th power is 35 to the 8th power
times 7 this piece right here is 35 to
the 8th power and then you have your 7
and then that is choice B right there
they just switch the order of the 75 the
7 and the 35 to the eighth power 21 use
the diagram below to answer the question
that follows ok they just have numbers
listed in order and they have 5 per row
which of the following algebraic
equations could best be used to explain
why for any 3x3
so it's 3x3 Crosse like the one shown
above the some of the numbers in the
vertical rectangle so this is the
vertical rectangle right there is equal
to the sum of the numbers in the
horizontal rectangle so the horizontal
rectangle the horizontal rectangle is
that right there so let's look at this a
little bit what's the sum in the
vertical rectangle if we call this
number X let me just draw it generally
let me draw as best I can
if that middle entry is X what's the
entry right above that well no matter
where you go is going to be 5 less and
that's cuz we have 5 per row right 14
minus 5 is 9 12 minus 5 is 7 8 minus 5
is 3 so this is going to be X minus 5 by
the same logic if you go down a row
you're adding 5 14 plus 5 is 19 15 plus
5 is 20 this is going to be X plus 5 so
the sum of the entries in the vertical
column write the sum of the numbers in
the vertical rectangle are X minus 5
plus X plus X plus 5 so that's the sum
in the vertical column and then in the
horizontal column if this is X what's
this going to be it's just 1 below that
it's X minus 1 and then to the right of
it is just X plus 1 so the sum and the
horizontal column is going to be X minus
1 plus X plus X plus 1 plus X plus 1 and
let's see if any of these choices look
like what I just wrote down a bunch of
nines
maybe so that simplifies nines and here
you go this looks very similar actually
this is exactly what I wrote up here if
you just switch the left and the right
hand side and you can do that consider
equality they wrote this here and they
wrote this here so this is what I could
use to prove that the sum of the
vertical rectangle is equal to the sum
of the horizontal if I wanted to keep
going you notice that these fives would
cancel out these ones would cancel out
you'd get 3x is equal to 3x and that
would be that would complete your proof
next problem next problem a landscaper
bought some decorative cement blocks
from a landscaping store the supplier
charged 5% sales tax and the total came
to $315 all right three hundred fifteen
after five percent without the tax the
landscaper could have bought six more
blocks for the same total cost how many
blocks did the landscaper buy all right
if P represents the price of one block
okay P is the price of one block in
which of the following equation says X
represent the answer to the problem
above remember answer the problem of is
how many blocks did the landscape or by
so x equals blocks X is equal to blocks
baht now this first equation says that
after paying five percent sales tax so
before tax
he bought X blocks he prayed P for each
of those blocks that's what they tell us
right here so this is the pre-tax price
P for blocks times X blocks is how much
he pays but he has to pay sales tax on
that it's to pay five percent of that on
top of that is sales tax o plus 0.05
that's the same thing as five percent
times whatever the pre-tax value is and
that's going to be equal to three
hundred and fifteen dollars three
hundred and fifteen and then this we
could just add the coefficients this is
a one out here right 1 plus 0.05 is 1.0
five times price times quantity is equal
to 315 and let's see if we have anything
like that over here in our answers which
which equation is X represent the answer
so a problem above C 0.95 PX no price
what six more without the tax so another
way you can think about it if you didn't
have tax $315 would have been the price
without tax so let's see if that
simplifies because I don't see exactly
what I wrote here from that first
equation so without the tax you could
have bought X plus
if there was no tax and so then the
total so he would have bought X plus six
for P per block and then that is going
to be equal to 315 this is a situation
with no tax if there's no tax for $315
he could have bought six more than he
originally bought so that's this is what
the second this let me graph it without
the tax so this first equation came from
the first sentence the second equation
comes from this red sentence right here
comes from this one right here let's see
if we see this anywhere P times P times
X plus 6 is equal to 315 I don't see
that anywhere here but we can see we can
do something interesting we can use all
of the information from the problem
remember the first problem of the it
said the supplier charged 5% sales tax
in the total came to 315 that gave us
this equation right here the second one
said without the tax without the text
for $315 you could have bought six and
more blocks so we get this one right
here notice both of these equations
equal 315 so we could set this equal to
that so we could say P times X plus 6 is
equal to one point zero five times price
times X and let's see if that looks like
anything we have here so we have we have
let's see P times X plus 6 is equal to 1
point 0 5 PX so the answer is C right
there we're just saying both of these
things equal 315 so we set them equal to
each other problem 23 a store that sells
handcrafted items let me pick a nice
highlighting color a store that sells
handcrafted items takes $3.00 per item
plus 40% of the sale price for each item
sold ok the rest of the money takes
$3.00 per item plus 40% of the sale
price for each item sold the rest of the
money from the item sales goes to the
crafts person that's nice
all items so sold cost $5 or more okay
if P represents the sale price of one
item of one item which of the following
expressions represents the amount of
money the crafts person gets for each
item sold so you start off with P that's
how much the customer gives and then the
store takes three dollars so it takes
three dollars so P minus three plus
forty percent of the sale price so not
40 percent of after the three dollars it
says plus forty percent of the sales
price so the store is gonna take another
forty percent right point four or 0.40
times the sales price so the store takes
three dollars and then 40 percent of the
sales price and this is what the crafts
person gets so this is what you know
this is this is our answer this is what
the crafts person gets so what do we
what is this this is P we switch colors
P minus 0.4 P is 0.6 P and then you have
the minus three that's what the crafts
person gets and if you look here you
don't see that answer they wrote it all
as fractions 0.6 is the same thing as
6/10 P minus 3 6 10 - the same thing is
3/5 P minus 3 so it's 3/5 p minus 3
choice D